my favorite film that's very very hard
to answer I could say at least 50 60
but there's one favorite scene in one of
my favorite films Fred Astaire I believe
it's in swing time and he's dancing with
his own shadows and he's casting three
shadows and dances exactly as if he were
casting the shadows and he stops in the
shadows start to dance on it it's just
magic that cinema
that's what cinema is all about I love
it all writing directing editing
recently also acting like in Jack
Reacher as a villain very hard for me to
to really tell you I love everything
that has to do with cinema
it's not easy to to give one single
advice but how can i express it mostly I
would say stick to your own vision you
should have the courage to do it and try
to become self-reliant because too many
young people are going into filmmaking
they are wasting so many years in trying
to get finances in finding a studio that
might sign them up and in the normal
cases it doesn't happen but for very
little money today for $10,000 you can
make a feature film we've seen that and
you should have the courage to earn to
your own vision so just go for it
roll up your sleeves